[Music]
from the magical mind of Jacob Olli and
the magical wallet of the Harry Potter
global franchise development e comes a
movie based on a real fake textbook
based on a fake real textbook briefly
mentioned into real Harry Potter books
boy we are really scraping the bottom of
the barrel here aren't we
fantastic beasts and where to find them
long after JK ran out of novels the
world still craves more Potter but
Hermione is way too famous these days
Harry is literally farting around and
Ron is where is Ron anyway now get ready
for a five part prequel that
isn't off to the best start who cares
man
that's pirate heads need a fix never
mind
maybe I'll go find my Patronus again
look I'm a salmon that's cool journey to
the uptight repressed society of 1920s
New York but beneath the surface lies a
magical world that's also really uptight
and repressed they've got their own
uncreated slang and no matter what no
magic their own muggle racism I know
that you have thought of backwards knows
about relations with non-magic people
and their own state-sponsored murder
jacuzzis um can we go back to Hogwarts
please once upon a time JK Rowling
insisted on only using British actors
but now the franchise has come to
America and everyone is still British
like fancy lad Newt Scamander the latest
of Eddie redmayne's whisper mumblers not
as bad wouldn't happen nice place
I will harvest the planet don't you
think this is okay he may not be
charming he may not be popular or not in
his 2015 school but he is willing to lie
to say this Pokemon at the cost of human
lives nothing in there is dangerous
these dr. Hoffman creatures they are
dangerous many trains come on they are
dangerous for the first symptom be
flames out of the dangerous they are
dangerous
they are dangerous we breathe the North
newts not alone in the big city move
over Ron tricho Snape and Hermione
because there's a far less interesting
gang in town like the boring tina
goldstein this psychic Betty boob random
Jon Voight family drama and the actually
likable Kowalski a muggle who steals the
show just by reacting to stuff Tim that
guy gives great face so come along in a
story that works well enough on its own
but isn't that promising as an intro to
a franchise oh because while the whole
world look welling up with Harry Potter
we all know what happens when Johnny
Depp plays a pale weirdo and no one ever
needs to see that again good morning
Starshine
the earth says hello starring Eddie
Redmayne talks to animals Cogan is Rob
the Pillsbury o face true our season two
for my knee
DTF scott Fitzgerald we need to talk
about Creedence
Avada Kedavra and AH fake monsters he
brought a zoo in teapot gee if only
there were a magic spell that could help
you out in this situation
hey screen junkies want to know even
more about fantastic beasts and where to
find them
then click the box on the right for our
guide to all of the Easter eggs hidden
in the movie if you're still feeling
honest click the box on the left to
watch another awesome honest trailer
Harry Potter you must go to the Shire
and become a Jedi Knight so you can sit
on the Iron Throne on his trailers is
filmed in front of an adorable live
audience farm-fresh butt nuggets for
sale at your mom's house I like
pineapples on pizza I honestly don't
even know what's in my sprite